all right well the problem with calling
anyone racist these days of course
is that the world you know the word is
like a a blank space in a mad lib
fill it in however you like it could
mean whatever you want it to mean
this is by design of course it's easier
to weaponize the racism label if you
don't have to worry about using the
label correctly
that's what makes the latest publicity
stunt from yelp so disturbing
now yelp has long been hated by some
small business owners who complain that
negative reviews on the site can have a
significant impact on their business
despite being potentially inaccurate or
malicious
a recent documentary actually called
billion dollar bully
claims that yelp essentially extorts
smaller companies
demanding that they they buy advertising
in exchange for minimizing negative
reviews that's what the documentary
claims yelp denies this charge and even
bought the billion bully.com domain name
and redirected it to a page on its own
site clarifying
or claiming anyway that it does not
extort small businesses now you can
judge for yourself whether buying the
domain name of a documentary that
accuses you of dishonest tactics
is itself a dishonest tactic
but we can say yelp's latest innovation
um which which which begs to be
exploited by bad actors
is an official business accused of
racist
behavior alert company explained the new
system in a series of tweets here's what
they said
today we're announcing a new consumer
alert to stand against racism
the last few months we've seen that
there is a clear need to warn consumers
about businesses associated with
egregious racially charged actions
to help people make more informed
spending decisions communities have
always turned to yelp in reaction to
current events
and our user operations team already
places alerts on business on business
pages when we notice an unusual uptick
in reviews
that are based on what someone may have
seen in the news rather than on
first-hand experience
now when a business gains attention for
reports of racist conduct
yelp will place a new business accused
of racist behavior alert
on their yelp page to inform users along
with a link to a news article where they
can learn more
now the the alert which you can see here
this will pop up for any business under
suspicion of racism
says in big bold letters business
accused of racist behavior and then it
explains
recently someone associated with this
business was accused of racist behavior
resulting in an influx of people posting
to their
their views to this page racism is
reprehensible and has no place on yelp
and we unequivocally reject racism in
any form
read about the reports of racist
behavior here while we
understand the desire to warn others
about racist behavior associated with a
business
all reviews on yelp must be must reflect
actual first-hand consumer experience
we have temporarily disabled the ability
to post here as we work to investigate
the content
could go wrong businesses will be tagged
with the scarlet
r and then yelp will investigate to see
if the claims are actually true
how will yelp know if they're true how
will a business owner prove
that a supposedly racist thing didn't
happen
or that a supposedly racist statement
wasn't made
classic case of guilty until proven
innocent and here there's no way at all
you could possibly prove your innocence
keep in mind
that racism is not just a vague and
ambiguous word
these days but also according to black
lives matter and other proponents of
critical race theory
it's a word that applies to all white
people inherently by
nature of their whiteness you know by
this way of thinking
any action taken or words spoken by a
white business owner
is automatically racist at some level
because racism is embedded in the
structures of whiteness or some such
nonsense
it would seem that the only evidence
needed to prove a racism charge against
a business owner is that business
owner's skin color
but not to worry if you run a small
company
you've already been decimated by covid
lockdowns perhaps rioting mobs on top of
it
and are now worried about being labeled
a racist by a vindictive customer or
hate crime hoaxer
yelp has resources to help yelp has
partnered with a group called
open to all quote to bring local
businesses a new toolkit that allows
them to
take the next step in creating an
inclusive community the toolkit includes
a 60-minute unlearning bias training
video for employees
outreach language for customers and
employees social media assets and more
and for just ten dollars you can get a
sticker to put on your window that
declares your business
open to all which hopefully will
convince the woke mob to spare you like
the angel of death
passing over the homes of the israelites
with lamb lambs blood smeared on their
doors
um the opentall website also has a
number of videos
that illuminate the discrimination and
racism issue
including this one i'll show you here
which condemns businesses that require
biological males
to use the men's restroom watch this
i'm a transgender woman i was born and
raised as a boy but inside i always knew
i was female
so i transitioned and now i live every
day as the woman i've always known
myself to be
it can be hard to understand what it
means to be transgender especially if
you've never met a transgender person
in most states our laws don't protect
transgender people from discrimination
in public places
or when it comes to using the restroom
something we all need to do every day
i have lived as a woman for many years
most people when they stop and think
about it
they realize that when businesses can
legally force me to use the men's room
it puts me at risk for harassment and
violence
safety and privacy in bathrooms are
important for all of us
it's already illegal to enter a restroom
to harm someone
and anyone who does that can and should
be arrested
obtaining the law to protect gay and
transgender people from discrimination
won't change that but it would help to
ensure that people like me
aren't mistreated when we need to do
something as basic as using the restroom
if you're wondering whether yelp will be
judging racism and discrimination
complaints fairly
there's your answer this is the radical
leftist lens through which yelp like so
many other billion dollar corporations
views the world no surprise given that
this is the same company
which a few months ago unveiled a new
search option making it easier for users
to find and support
specifically black owned businesses this
is quite blatantly
racial segregation and discrimination
but it's the good kind according to the
far left
and potentially destroying innocent
business owners by
enabling libelers and slanderers to
smear them as racist without evidence
is also good if it advances the cultural
agenda
we could only hope that the first
business owner unfairly targeted
by the racism alert we'll be able to
afford a high priced attorney and can
sue yelp
into bankruptcy because based on this it
seems they certainly deserve it
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends